buta co was an ancient celtic warrior
queen who led an army in rebellion
against the roman empire the story of
this brave woman's life has often been
reduced to just a few sentences in a
textbook and that's because there's very
little known about her life there were
just two Roman historians Tacitus and
Kassius do who wrote down information
about booty caps so everything we know
about her
it's rather skewed from the enemy's
perspective and both of their versions
of the story vary slightly from the
other but even from this biased
standpoint we can still see her bravery
and her determination to protect her
people despite the fact that we know so
little about her life she still has made
a massive impact and she very nearly
defeated one of the largest empires in
the world
she is Sturm to this day as being an
epic hero in British history
[Music]
the term Celt is used to refer to the
ancient people of the United Kingdom but
it covers the Gaels Britons and ghouls
just to name a few there were dozens of
different independent tribes that were
certainly not united so while their
lifestyles were often very similar they
each had their own customs languages and
traditions so the name celts is just a
way for historians to refer to this
ancient society the celts did not keep
their own written records so much of
what we know from them comes from roman
records and archaeological dicks
according to the Romans Celtic warriors
often fought naked or at least with
their shirts off their bodies and faces
they were painted with intricate designs
which earns them the nickname
pict switch fence the painted people
they weren't known for being incredibly
brutal and during battle they would
begin grunting like animals and blue
loud horns to start all their enemies
they beheaded the Romans without
hesitation because they apparently
believed that a man's head contains his
power and his soul despite their
barbaric war strategy these were also
very intelligent people they were the
first society to invent chainmail which
protected them from enemies swords both
men and women wore gold necklaces that
included intricate designs paved roads
were also a Celtic invention even though
the Romans later tried to claim that
they came up with the idea first so in a
lot of ways the Celts were far from
being the bumbling brutes that they're
often made out to be
Boadicea was the queen and wife of king
Prasutagus and they were rulers of the
Iceni tribe they were located in
modern-day Norfolk and Suffolk and for a
while their people they lived in peace a
Roman statesman and historian named
Cassius Dio described Boudicca as such
in stature she was very tall in
appearance most terrifying in the glance
of her eye most fierce and her voice was
harsh a great mass of the Tor newest
hair fell to her hips around her neck
was a large golden necklace and she wore
a tunic of divers colours over which a
thick mantle was fastened with brooch
woe Boudicca apparently lacked in grace
and beauty she made up for with
brilliance according to dears backhanded
compliments she possessed of greater
intelligence than often belongs to women
in Celtic society druids were
intellectuals who held very highly
respected positions in their respective
tribes they were like priests who
performed the pagan
rituals but they also practice medicine
alchemy science and philosophy and yes
druids could be women too since Boudicca
is remembered for being very smart it
would make sense that she may have been
a druid in her spare time
apart from being Queen this would have
only made her a more well-respected
leader but with the new threat of Roman
invasion
Boadicea would need to focus on
protecting her people more than ever
before
[Music]
the Romans conquered southern England in
King prestigious could see that his
Celtic warriors were no match for the
Roman legion so he ordered his warriors
to stop their rebellion prestigious
agreed to align with the Roman Empire
for the sake of protecting what remained
of his people he promised that when he
died his tribe would be under Roman rule
in his last will and testament he left
his lands to his two daughters and to
the emperor of Rome the King truly did
believe that they had made a peaceful
negotiation and the Romans even lent to
Britain their currency and helped them
to integrate into their new society they
were given 40 million sesterces but they
were expected to pay at makeover time
plus interest there is a debate over how
much once Esther I would actually be
worth in today's money but the estimates
usually around about one dollar and
fifty cents so their loan was
essentially for sixty million dollars
the Britons never asked for a loan in
the first place in fact the Celtic
tribal people were rich in resources
like goals but they accepted the money
anyway because it was the only way that
they could have a currency to buy and
sell with the Romans Nero took
Claudius's place as the new emperor of
Rome in the year 54 he was just 16 years
old at the time and he was known for his
extravagant spending in turn he sought
to regain much of the lost funds by
going after interest on loans as well as
through taxes Nero appointed a man named
swear Tonia's Paul earnest to handle the
new territory that was England he was
given the position of governor of Great
Britain and he was also the general of
the Roman army in the Year 60 King
prestigeous he died and Queen Boudicca
became the new leader of the Iceni tribe
of course the Romans did not see
Boudicca as a legitimate leader because
she was a woman as we mentioned earlier
there were certain contracts in place
before King prestigious death that
should have guaranteed his people safety
that's general Paulinus he decided to
ignore all of this and take the Iceni by
force he used the loan as an excuse and
he demanded that he wanted all 40
million sesterces to be paid back in
full plus interest and he needed it all
back immediately the Romans went into
every single home taking anything of
value that they could find they captured
men as slaves and they raped the young
women not even the young princesses were
spared but his daughters were sexually
assaulted by remin soldiers when she
tried to rescue her daughters the
soldiers grabbed
the Queen ripped her clothes off and
beat up bloody in front of her people
since King prestiges truly did leave
their plan to the Romans the Celts could
only stand and watch as their beloved
Queen was brutalized in front of them
Boadicea had been beaten but she was not
broken
instead of withering and self-pity this
attack it only sparked her need for
revenge
Boadicea called a meeting with the
leaders of the local tribes and learns
that they had all been treated in the
same way everyone was furious at what
the Romans had done the leaders of
several Celtic tribes they all agreed to
put aside their differences and follow
her as their new queen it was clear that
if the Celts wanted their freedom they
were going to have to fight for it
[Music]
Boadicea had witnessed her husband's
defeat against the Romans years earlier
and yes she was not afraid to fight them
once again for her people's freedom
armed with a sword and her horse-drawn
chariot Boudicca stood in front of her
Celtic warriors just like her men her
face would have been adorned in battle
paint women were fighting alongside men
and each and every one of them at the
fire of vengeance in their hearts the
Celts began the rebellion by targeting
the Roman city of Camulodunum which is
modern-day Colchester she waited until
general Paulinus was out of town and he
took his troops with him he was on a
campaign to capture Anglesey which is an
island in Wales since he took all of his
soldiers with him he left Camulodunum
virtually undefended once he was gone
Boudicca and her men they entered the
city and they slaughtered all of the
Roman men that they could find when
Roman leadership got word that they
needed help defending the city from a
tribal queen who was leading a rebellion
they grossly underestimated her and she
was a woman
they sent a measly 200 unarmed slaves to
take care of the issue obviously this
handful of men were nothing but a
massive army of a hundred and twenty
thousand people an additional 2,500
Bremen soldiers were sent to help defend
the city for several days the soldiers
tried to keep civilians alive by
hoarding themselves in the temple of
Claudius the Celts grew tired of waiting
and they set fire to the temple which
trapped and killed everyone inside when
general Paulinus returns of the city he
found the temple crumbling in a pile of
ashes well as the gruesome scene of the
headed men dissected bodies and pools of
blood he knew that his small Legion of
5000 men would be no match for Boudicca
so he had no choice but to ride ahead to
each major Roman stronghold and try to
evacuate civilian refugees before it was
too late historian Cassie sto wrote all
this ruin was brought upon the Romans by
a woman a facts which in itself caused
them the greatest shame next the Celts
moved on to Londinium which is as you
would imagine modern day London's they
burned the entire city to the ground
while in London tribal men who had been
enslaved by the Romans they were set
free and they began to follow Boudicca
her army temporarily grew to over
230,000 troops they sacked the city
'verily neom which is modern-day Saint
Albans it is estimated that budahas army
killed and tortured between 70 fowls
to 80,000 Roman people in the history
books they described the celtic
slaughter as being truly barbaric some
modern-day historians believed that this
imagery was exaggerated in order to
demonize the Celtic culture just like
every other colonizing nation the Romans
believed that they were the more
civilized ones even though they started
the fight by attacking robbing and
raping the Celtic people beforehand
Boadicea and the rest of the Celts were
steadily making progress to regain the
britain's independence from the roman
empire at this point emperor nero was
seriously considering pulling his roman
troops out of Great Britain if Boudicca
kept up killing his people at such a
rapid rage she could topple the entire
Empire and if she had succeeded at that
she would have gone down in history as
the queen who united the Celtic tribes
under a common cause and regains their
independence but unfortunately for
Jandra Paulinus was confident that he
would win he convinced Emperor Nero to
stay because he was ready with a
strategy that was going to take down the
resistance once and for all
[Music]
the final confrontation was known as the
Battle of Watling Street as the name
suggests the two armies met at a Roman
Road called Watling Street while there
is a map of this road most historians
disagree over the exact location because
there is only a brief description of the
location given by the historian Takas
general pool owners chose this location
because it was ideal for his defensive
strategy the forest protected the back
of the Roman soldiers so they could not
be attacked from behind further there
was an open field in front of the forest
which forced boudicca's army to charge
straight towards them as mentioned
earlier general Paulinus only had five
thousand soldiers in his army he had to
send a letter to all of the veterans
living in Great Britain who were much
older and enjoying their retirement
luckily for him an additional five
thousand men were still loyal to the
Empire and he was able to assemble a
total of ten thousand troops even after
calling for backup he was outnumbered by
otakus army according to reminisce
during and Kassius do Queen Boudicca
spent time before the battle giving a
long and riveting speech about fighting
for freedom that rather sounds like it's
straight out of a Hollywood movie it
reads if you weigh well the strengths of
our armies you will see that in this
battle we must conquer or die this is a
woman's resolve as for the men they may
live or be slaves I am NOT fighting for
my kingdom and wealth now I am fighting
as an ordinary person for my lost
freedom my bruised body and my outraged
daughters however Casius do wasn't even
there to listen and in fact there were
very few witnesses who actually survived
therefore we can't be sure if the speech
was actually like this at all this is
especially the case when we considered
that she spends a lot of time trying to
convince her troops that even though
she's just a woman they should still
trust her anyway if you really think
about it a hundred thousand Celts
wouldn't really be there if they didn't
trust her in the first place
further archaeological evidence suggests
that Celts had given women positions of
power in the military for hundreds of
years before this but we'll get to that
later
the Celts they're plenty of weapons and
plenty of supplies that they had
scavenged from the various Roman cities
that they had defeated
however they were still not as well
equipped as the Roman army Roman
soldiers they wore full suits of armor
helmets and had sandals with nails at
the bottom to help them from slipping in
the grass they also had swords and large
shields their spears they could be
thrown long distances which helped them
to avoid
hand-to-hand combat despite these
setbacks the Celtic people were so
confident that they would win the battle
that they even brought a wagon train
with their wives and children
the wagons formed a semicircle around
the back of the celtic army sealing off
the exit according to records general
poorness could see the fear in his men's
eyes as they stand at this army that was
ten times larger than their own but he
used insults to snap the fear out of his
men he tried to boost their morale by
mocking the enemy he said that the Celts
were savages and pointed to the female
warriors as evidence that they were
weaker than the Romans just like he did
with Boudica the historian cassia Stier
invented yet another long and grandiose
speech for general pulling us to say to
his troops well we might not know
exactly what words were exchanged we do
know what the generals battle strategy
was he knew that even though his army
had fewer men that they had a great
advantage with their technology the
Roman soldiers stood side-to-side and
crouched together behind their shields
during the first rounds of battle the
Celts charge towards the Romans who
threw their spears into the air without
having metal armor to protect them the
spears went through the chain Maryland
the bare chests of the Celtic warriors
who to get told the men's ax fall back
before pressing on once more when the
Celts pushed up against this wall of
Roman shields the Romans would draw
their swords and stab the men in the
chests every few minutes the Roman
soldiers would rotate and the man who
was just fighting was moved to the back
of the line this way each man was fresh
and ready for battle and he gave
everyone a chance to rest after the
Celts had exhausted thousands of their
soldiers general Paul earnest gave the
order for his men to push themselves
together into a triangular formation
they then charged towards the Celtic
army this was a very powerful maneuver
that pushed against the men and it
forced the Celtic people to retreat
kasia's di wrote the remains it took to
flight although escape was difficult as
the cordon of wagons had blocked the
outlets the troops gave no quarter even
to the women the baggage animals
themselves had been speared and added to
the pile of bodies according to Roman
records 80,000 Celtic men women and
children were killed during the Battle
of Watling Street and just four hundred
Roman soldiers died at the hands of
boudicca's army
after losing the battle records say that
Buddakan managed to run what we do not
know what happened next hazard is
speculated that she would have poisoned
herself because it would have been the
honorable thing to do at the time have
acacias do wrote that she had later died
of an illness ultimately we do not know
when or how rudika died four years a
story it was over forgotten this was an
embarrassing stain in the Roman Empire's
history so it only made sense that it
was buried for quite some time but
during the Renaissance the story of the
Celtic Queens bravery began to emerge
once again she was remembered and she
was painted by artists and during the
Victorian era statues were created in
her honor it didn't take long before she
became a British icon
despite the detailed Roman record some
people began to wonder if she even
existed at all and considered a
possibility that this warrior Queen may
have actually just been a legend in fact
even the name Boudicca comes from the
Celtic word meaning victorious at the
very least there is a chance that
Boudicca may not have been her real name
means it was just a placeholder put in
place of her true identity it was in the
Victorian era that boudicca's Fame
finally took on legendary proportions as
Queen Victoria came to be seen as
boudicca's namesake their names being
identical in meeting victoria's poet
laureate Alfred Lord Tennyson wrote a
poem
Boadicea and several ships were named
after her in 2001 archaeologists
uncovered a burial site of a Celtic
female warrior who was laid to rest with
a huge amount of respect at her feet
were small treasures including a mirror
brooch and blue glass beads a chariot it
was decorated with red coral gathered
from the sea two other soldiers were
buried next to this woman and a chariot
these are known as the wet wine graves
and all of the artifacts from the
archaeological sites they're now kept at
the British Museum according to Tony
Spence who works at the Department of
prehistory in Europe for the British
Museum they believe that this woman was
a queen because of the special care and
respect that was given to her remains
her chariots and the other objects
surrounding her were also so expensive
only royalty you could afford such an
extravagant burial she would have been
in her late 30s to early 40s and she was
very tall they were also able to use her
skulls do a facial reconstruction of
what she would have looked like her face
was disfigured so it's easy to see how
she could be described as frightening
just like how Cassius Dio described
Boudica despite the fact that nearly
every detail seems to line up with us
story of Boudica carbon-dating done by
oxford university in 2017
placed these artifacts anywhere between
the years of 145 to 200 bc which would
have been about two to three hundred
years before boudicca's battle took
place beside dusts are now saying that
carbon dating has a potential to be
wrong in 2018 Cornell University did an
experiment which showed proof of carbon
dating that was offset by several
hundred years this means that many of
the historical timelines we've been
taught about ancient civilizations could
actually be rather wrong without a
written record or until we invent a time
machine we may never know the full story
behind the true identities of these
people in those graves and indeed it
will probably remain an unsolved mystery
forever but whether the wet wine grave
belongs to Boudicca or not it still
proves undoubtedly that the celts
included warrior women in battle and if
they were really two hundred years
before bodegas time it only goes to show
that in ancient Britain women were
respected enough to lead armies for
several generations the remains of this
warrior queen may sit in plastic bags
and cardboard boxes in a museum but the
spirit of these leaders are still very
much alive in the hearts of everyone who
stands up against their oppressors even
if she was on the losing side of the war
Boudica truly was a hero so I really
hope you found that video interesting
and inspiring if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several days a
week if you hit that Bell button as well
you find out about when we put these
videos out so why not do that give it a
like all of that good stuff and as
always I'll see you next time
[Music]